you have a special intro for this one I
think so um lixian play the normal music
that you ordinarily play at the
beginning of these it's really special
and custom-made just for this
thank you
welcome to power wash Pals also known as
the power wash Power Hour
also known as power wash
that was another one the power wash
podcast
ah I do not have a third podcast you
just said that this is a podcast no no I
said it was also known as that's an
alias it's not actually what it is okay
um so I I took the liberty of picking
the map for you I thought the playground
was fitting
um it has the brightest colors and you
know it's the most reminiscent of our
youth and youth is slowly slipping away
from you uh day by day Moment by moment
so I thought you know the time never
stops the clock
is always ticking
that in such a perfect rendition of the
voice you said it in before I I suddenly
got flashbacks
so this is uh the channel name uh or is
comes later because that's the AKA this
is uh Ethan Nestor uh also known as a
one crank gameplays uh lyxian please
play lyxian or uh Ethan's intro
there it is good job Lexi you've been
doing YouTube for just about 10 years
now a very long time uh we've known each
other for about seven
ah seven years seven years which is a
considerable amount of time that's weird
to think about I know right isn't it
weird odd yeah yeah and uh uh one third
of the no longer with us project Unis
honest
um some people would think one half but
it was that there was a third party that
was incredibly essential to the success
of that project
Evan welcome to the show
oh thank you thank you thank you very
excited to very excited to be on here
tonight you know yeah yeah are you it's
great and Grand I I watched the episode
with uh with you and Sean it was real
nice well I didn't I listened to it I
was like oh this is this would be a nice
thing to to put on in the back it is
really nice just like I don't know
because I feel like we're always sort of
on whenever we record videos and so it
was nice to just like you guys just talk
and I know right
just chill yeah not these fake reactions
that we we always do and every YouTuber
does everything's fake when when you
know this is this is Ethan and Mark not
crank gameplays and markiplier no way
and definitely not Unis and honest
they're not dead they're dead and gone
and gone and not coming back and at the
end of space it was not ooh honest it
was a darkiplier but whatever you know
who's to say who it was time to say I
wrote the show I did the thing I guess
maybe
God this is what this is what I give for
like just trying to be like oh I'll just
put a step into it because uh not many
people know that you filmed that uh
particular thing at any point in the
filming process of that moment where you
like hey people might think this might
be when it's honest or something like
this do you think not at all no I
thought darkiplier the whole time
because I was the line such a fickle
oh I can smell your bones oh you silly
cow you silly cow I still want to like
download that video and redo the voice
and re-upload it just so stop
yeah that'll go over well
sure ask me permission to make a cartoon
about me I think it'd be fine they'd be
honored they'd be honored right honored
honored yes honored
so going back to the uh uh Unison since
we're talking about it uh we'll go ahead
and like cover that topic a lot of
people thought after Unison ascended and
for those of you who didn't don't know
what Unison was don't try to look it up
it doesn't exist all those videos you
see on YouTube they're not real they're
not they're all deep fakes
by the AI yes the AI and uh it's a
project that uh Ethan and I and Amy and
Evan also helped and all the editors
helped with you know Lexi and Marcus
Rachel Vincent
um they were helping us make this
project that was about the temporary
nature of the world and life and it's
finite limits so what what uh what did
you think if you had to summarize
unisonis in uh one sentence let's make
it 10 words or less what oh 10 words or
less
um I guess I would just say hmm
a brain Tickler this early into the show
oh man
um I don't I mean I feel like you just
summarized it pretty well it was just uh
uh a project to symbolize the temporary
nature of life and also the internet
because I think a lot of people uh just
have that thought of like oh my favorite
YouTuber is going to be making videos
forever
uh and I'll always be able to watch
these videos and it's like YouTube could
disappear at any moment it could it
literally could and probably in the
future it might because as far as I know
I don't know who's keeping the records
of that but it might just be Google and
if YouTube goes down all of a sudden
that's probably because Google went down
all of a sudden and all that will be
disappeared Into The Ether
just like Unison all the videos what I
just said was not 10 words or less but
uh you know it's it's fine it's okay I
didn't expect you to count it's all good
man nah it's uh we're coming up on the
two-year uh and not an anniversary what
are they what they call you a
deathaversary
celebration of life uh-huh yeah
something like that what what do they
call that there's another word it's like
not immemorium it's not a
memorialization I don't know someone on
someone in the comments you know Lexi
and look up the word
on the screen you know how English isn't
your first language like seeing you know
this word looking you know this one you
know what we're talking about look at
you and your funny little animation that
you you Bob in your head and then yeah
don't make fun hey actually interact
with them like Pokemon poke them you can
poke them
yeah it feels powerful right no but uh
weird thinking about that it's already
been two years yeah
um I think about this all the time
um I don't I honestly thinking back I
don't know how we did it you know that's
what everyone asks us how did you do
that and I'm kind of like starting to
realize yeah how did we do how did we do
that like how did we one just make those
videos every day but two how did we not
just completely go insane uh kind of did
that's true a little bit but I I think
it's um to your credit it really is like
the power of your ability to make
anything a bit
um I would say I have that ability but I
don't think I I don't think my ability
is nearly as much as yours you for some
reason your chaotic energy just really
carried it nice I think I spent most of
those videos just desperately trying to
get you back on quote-unquote track but
in all honesty your bits were better
tracks than what whatever the setup
actually was so it was like this fun
push-pull Dynamic uh that that kept the
videos like always engaging
um it's just like uh it's just like for
some reason your brain is chaos and my
brain is also chaos but like desperately
trying to adhere to order so yeah I
think that's what kept uh the energy
going for 367 videos
well thank you I appreciate that I don't
know I wouldn't I wouldn't I I wouldn't
say it's really an ability to keep a bit
going I think it's the inability to
focus on the task at hand an inability
to hold on to reality really yeah that's
the struggle exactly that's what it is
no like all credit to you man like um
there were some days I was just [ __ ]
beating I was not into anything and it
was just like as soon as uh the camera
turns on yeah you know I know
it is kind of like I get possessed by
some other being no I I think that's
that's the thing that was so great about
unisonis um and something that I really
miss is like the collaborative side of
things because obviously like both of us
were never like on point every day doing
that and so it was really cool having
that that push and pull and having some
people pull a little harder on some days
and I don't know just being able to work
together on stuff like that was so much
fun
um yeah I miss that kind of stuff a lot
I do too I don't miss the Daily Grind of
it but I do miss the like it was it
really gave a sense of purpose I was
talking to John about this actually
because he just uh he retired from the
military and uh one of the things that
he's mentioned uh comes in the veterans
packet and the informational and like
the counseling that they private provide
is like be prepared to lose your sense
of purpose you know transitioning to
civilian life and he at first was like
you know what was that about I'll have
purpose I'll do my uh do my fabrication
my costumes my art I'll focus on me I'll
try to keep a roof over my head out of
purpose but really when you have that
unified goal in its go go whether that's
good or bad I'm not saying it's right or
wrong but in the military you know it's
like just like you have to do these
things you have to follow orders you
have to follow a regiment
um those kind of constraints can give
you purpose especially if it's towards a
unified goal with other people
um and then suddenly removing that like
can be jarring
um and for me with uh coming out of
Unison is what I really realize is you
know I we talked about this this at the
end of the Unison it was like hard for
me to let go of the idea of the mark
show you know like you mentioned this to
me and it was just like that that was
hard but what I realized is
it was great once I was able to kind of
like yield to other people's creative
ideas and really like accept what they
were taking in instead of trying to like
control the situation all the time or
control the bit or have to be in charge
it helped me a lot and right now I'm
working with Corridor uh digital I'm I'm
their intern where I'm literally just
like I'm just doing whatever they what
then whatever they tell me to do
um and it's great uh I have my ideas of
my own that I inject all the time and of
course they asked me for advice you know
they do respect the things that I know
but it's it's great because it's a
collaborative environment and I get to
work with other people again I I do miss
that about yes
yeah I miss I missed that a lot I I
think I learned so
much like not only about myself but just
about like I don't know how to how to
like survive on the internet without
like losing yourself because I think
like so many of those videos are
inherently stupid that we made but I've
I've never had more fun making videos
than when we did unisonis and I think
that really captured the essence of like
this might sound a little like arrogant
but what it should mean to be like a
Creator you know because we were like
making really stupid weird ideas but it
was so much fun yeah and like the videos
were good not necessarily because the
ideas behind them were like crazy
over-the-top spectacular things but
because like we had a good time making
them and like we were just having fun
and like being goofy and stuff and
that's that's the kind of stuff that I I
think in some parts of YouTube are
lacking nowadays where like Feels Like
Everything has to be this big huge
spectacle and it feels like the heart
isn't in it as much you know it's just
like making a thing with huge stakes and
like we I don't know it is it seems like
there's not as much heart in it and I
feel like with every video that we did
for unisonis that was like at the core
was just having fun and being stupid and
getting a fun video out of it yeah I I
think you're right I I do think that
there is that not not everywhere it's
not yeah across the entire platform
there's definitely people that do put in
an incredible amount of like Creative
Juice into each video without worrying
about it like being crazy
um and there is a place for higher
production but but you are right like I
do think that a lot of other creators
might feel more free if they remember
that like this job is supposed to be fun
and it's supposed to entertain people
and yes big concept videos can do that
and there is a place for that but at the
same time like it's just about turning
on a camera and being yourself really
really that's what it is however I do
have to say we did have a big
overarching huge thing that we were
trying to rock the internet about and we
did so there was that I do have to point
that out there was that yeah what was
that I still blow people's mind when I
tell them how many people were at the uh
final live stream you know yeah it's
it's crazy yeah like I that was
something that I didn't really realize
until unisonis was was over because I
felt like I was so caught up in the
day-to-day of like making sure that
videos were going out and like filming
and everything that and like I feel like
I I'm not used to that kind of impact
because and I don't know maybe you did
feel this way but like you have been
one of the most predominant figures on
YouTube for a while
um and I feel like with unisonis that
was one of the first times that it was
like oh like everyone is talking about
this
um and it was a very weird thing that
didn't hit me until after where I was
like oh this like really had a big
impact and like
you know while it's not about how many
people watch the videos or how many
people were subscribed it was like oh
wow like the internet knew about this
and that's like kind of weird yeah
um it's it's bizarre for those of you
who don't know at the moment of deletion
I believe we had 1.6 million concurrent
live viewers not views on the video
literally 1.6 million people live
watching us to see if we'd actually
delete it
um and so that is a number uh I you or I
will never reach that in term of Life
viewers ever again not even close I
don't think until if unless one of us
dies live on stream live on stream live
stream stream that is that it would
never be achieved and even then I don't
think it would be and I'd be I'd be sad
if there was an afterlife and I was
looking down I'm like oh come on guys
just not even over 500 000 really but uh
no that that had meaning and it was like
part of the the whole message was just
like adhering to the meaning that we
agreed upon in the beginning even
setting out of it is just like yeah
we're gonna delete it and no one could
really believe that we would because but
that was good because it was toddler
contract creators was like yes you can
let go of something yeah you can do
something that's just for the fun of it
or the meaning of one meaning of it and
then it's done and that's fine in fact
sometimes it's better I actually talked
about this on Logan Paul's podcast of
all things actually not of all things
because after Unison was deleted he
actually made a point to say like that
unusas was an incredibly smart idea and
I was very grateful that he said that
yeah I saw that it's weird because
unisonis I think is the thing that's
given me the most closure in my entire
life like it was so satisfying having a
goal and having having a clear end date
and being like okay we're gonna do this
thing and then it's gonna be done one
like forever in the finality of having
to delete everything and it be
completely over was bittersweet
obviously but it was so gratifying and
it meant so much that like we finally
did it and I I think about this a lot
where the ending of unisonis like
literally the ending live stream people
will never be able to experience what we
felt with that but also we'll never be
able to experience the I think the
heartache side that fans did in the
sense that for us it was 54321 the
stream is over we delete the channel and
then we celebrate it and we were like we
[ __ ] did it for everyone else in the
entire world for the rest of the 1.6
million people it was five four three
two one Darkness yeah that was it wow
yeah and like
that's something that I think about a
lot where it's like wow like that must
be really weird for people that went
through that and then
it was truly done because at least we
got to like live in it for a little bit
and celebrate and be like we're done
blah blah and we all hung out after but
yeah for everybody else it was just
darkness and it was done yeah wow I I
didn't really like think about that
until you just said that that's
absolutely true for them it was and it
was a it was like an experience we
custom made them to feel
um but yeah I guess I never really
thought about the ramifications
um but I I would ask like that feeling
of isolation for us I think maybe hit a
bit not as intense right away but maybe
like this lingering ache came in I want
to ask you like how was it afterwards
like when you were back just to doing
your videos being crank gameplays like
that transition
um what was it like for you I think
going back to what you were saying
before about what John said I think I
did have this sort of lack of purpose in
a way like I I felt like what I was
doing on my own channel wasn't profound
enough and I did I remember for probably
a month or two after I would have like I
would have like stress dreams about
unisonis or like wake up and be like ah
is the video up does it have the correct
timer on it yeah
um
but yeah I definitely felt that like oh
that was really impactful
maybe I'll never do something like that
again and I mean like I've come to terms
with the fact that I won't but it was
definitely that like oh
this is weird like that is done now
uh and I have to I have to move on hmm
um
yeah I don't know it was it was
interesting and it was very Bittersweet
but it was sad and I think on my end the
saddest part about it
um even though it it was nice for a bit
to like get space from you and Amy but
it was sad where it was just like oh man
like we spent basically every day
together for a year like trying to come
up with stuff and then it was just like
all right that's done
um bye-bye bye-bye you know and it sucks
because we'll never make anything ever
together again because we're not friends
anymore of course yeah no I I this is
actually the first time we've had a
conversation since that um
it took a lot to get on the Discord I
wanted to cancel so badly it did yeah
actually if I think my rides here I
gotta go oh okay
uh but no yeah I I think it's it is that
for me too it was the lingering like
yeah it's done it's done
all right
whoa
oh
it's done yeah but then I I would say
like I I don't think you should say you
you will never do anything as profound
ever again because I I think you'll
surprise you yourself with what you're
able to make I know that afterwards like
I got busy with space immediately
afterwards
um but you started working on the secret
project and I remember this because you
would not tell a soul what it actually
was you made it a point so that no one
could know no one should know and no one
would know what you were working on but
that you were working on something yeah
you want to talk about that yeah that so
that let me see how far I guess that was
in uh February that I started so the
February after Unison
um yeah so I I was working on the live
show that I that I toured
um and that that's something that I
talked about in therapy a lot
was why I didn't want to tell anybody
about it
um I think a big reason was
being a person that is constantly like
making stuff for the internet and the
internet immediately sees everything I I
didn't want to and there's always that
pressure of like oh I need to get a
video out and nothing can ever like be
perfect or whatever but I I didn't want
to tell anybody about it because I I
wanted it to be done before anybody saw
it like I wanted
I wanted it to be ready and I didn't
want
there were so many times where I I
thought about like trying to Hype it up
but I just I didn't I didn't want
anybody to know about anything about it
until it was ready because For the first
time in a really long time I had control
over that you know and it was just like
okay like I'm I don't have to share any
of this like I can I can wait until it's
at a point where I feel comfortable and
then surprise people with it
um but yeah I was I was extremely
protective over the show like even Mika
my girlfriend for those of you who don't
know she didn't see anything about the
show at all
um like she knew that I was gonna do a
show where I told her that much but she
didn't see anything at all until two
days before the first show so she came
to the last rehearsal that I did
um before doing the first tester show
and that was the first time that she saw
anything uh that's wild yeah and so like
she would come into my my office and I
would like minimize everything on my
computer and I would be like frantic and
I'd be like what do you want and she'd
be like what are you doing and I'm like
I'm just working on the show
um and like I can't thank her enough for
being cool with that because I didn't I
didn't want her to think that like she
wasn't special enough to see it or that
I didn't trust her enough but it it
really was on all fronts like I I just
didn't want to show it to anybody I
didn't want to tell anybody about it
until I was ready to
um so I was super super grateful that
she was cool with that and that she
didn't feel like offended by that or
anything you never went oh it's porn
did you ever use the show as an excuse
when you were looking at porn
yeah oh it's a show works very really
hard oh my God I got a piece of paper
under my desk I'm writing by hand to
find it who helps me think I can't wait
to see the show it's great oh man
[Laughter]
yeah but that that was
um I think the show was something that
something that I've made myself that I'm
the most proud of out of anything I've
ever made because I truly like obviously
like I had I had a lot of help from
um the team out real good touring and
everything like that but it was like
something that I made and it was my
vision and I I don't know it was like my
little baby
um and you know obviously like anything
else there's parts of it that I wish I
did a little bit more on or there's
ideas now that I look back at where I'm
like uh I could have done that better
but like it was something and even now
still like I still really love the show
that I made and every night going to do
it like I I had a lot of fun
um and it was something that I had
wanted to do for such a long time and
I'm really proud that like I finally did
it yeah
I saw the show it was very good like no
joking about anything it was incredibly
good it was one of the best if not the
best uh YouTuber show I've ever seen I
think thank you I do think it was a far
more entertaining than the you're
welcome tour and I I say that like being
the guy like who was a part of the
you're welcome tour and was there uh I I
think your show was
um it was unique it had a lot of better
flow there was like the jokes really
landed the the bits were really well
thought together I won't spoil any of it
I don't know if you're ever gonna do it
again but
um like uh it was just it was really
well thought out and it was so clearly
yours and I think that that's another
thing like I totally understand the idea
of being very protective of of your
ideas and not letting anyone in
um I I've operated for so long just like
being the only one coming up with my
ideas and so it's like my default not to
really tell any about it just because
like I'm just thinking about my head but
I get that from coming from munis honest
and like having to share and collaborate
and everyone's ideas and some ideas are
like voted down versus up where it's
just like purely on your shoulders but
that can be stressful too like um it
runs the risk of you falling into what
you were saying before about content
creation where you know it should just
be about having fun but then there is
that pressure of like okay I have a
standard that has been set I guess I
have to exceed it for not for everyone
else's benefit but for my own validity
in terms of like self-worth like do you
ever think about that
yeah I mean that was that was sort of
like the whole thing about the show was
like because I had wanted to do that for
such a long time
um and that's why the show is called I
have to do the show is like amongst
viewers a lot of the times it was just
like oh like his manager is making him
or like it's a joke but it truly was
like I named the show that to force
myself to do it because I I wanted to
prove to myself that I could do better
than I had ever done and that I could
make something that I could make
something that I could like truly be
proud of long term you know because
there are like videos that I've been
proud of and stuff but like something
that I worked really hard on for a
really long time and be truly proud of
and something that was was challenging
and like that was the
that was the hardest part about it was
following through with something that
was so new to me that I had never done
before
um and like having to follow through
with it because obviously there was a
ton of times where I was like I don't
think that this is good
um but having to like conquer that fear
and be like nope like it might not be
good but I need to I need to follow
through with it I don't know the the
show was the show was very personal and
like a a really big a really big deal
for me and I think it was a really big
stepping stone
um and I think like I think it was also
big for me
and I hope that you don't take this the
wrong way that I could make something
that I could make something impactful
and have it also be successful without
you being attached to it
no I get that that's perfectly villain I
get that yeah no offense taken if
anything that sounds like this sounds
like I'm a beacon of success so I take
it as a compliment you are
oh no no I I think you you got it really
in terms of like the success metric it
was it was incredibly successful it's
hard to get people to turn up in public
you know especially nowadays um but it's
it's one of those things that really
goes to show how much people matter I or
how much people matter to how um I'll
watch you and fix this how much you
matter to people yes that one thank you
very much look soon all right guys it's
all good taken care of
but um I was talking about this with the
corridor guys and the corridor crew guys
you know all of them uh but I was
talking to Nico and Sam and specifically
I was trying to tell them how much their
videos meant to people because I'm sure
you've watched Corridor Crew videos or
at least Corridor Digital videos yeah I
I watched them before I started doing
YouTube there were an inspiration for me
to start I wanted to make videos like
that
um and it was jarring for me to hear how
much and how long they struggled to just
keep making things to just be able to
keep the lights on in their office and
the dream alive to continue making
videos how hard it was to adhere to like
a certain level of quality to to just
put out a video so that they could get
the money to be able to make another
video like that was their life for a
very long time and all we see as
consumers of the content was wow these
are really high quality videos I wish
they made more you know it's just and
and yet
um what I what I was telling them is
like you know from their perspective
it's like with the Unison everyone has
their perspectives they Sprint for two
weeks straight and as hard as they can
trying to do these VFX which are
incredibly time consuming things with an
original video content and being with
the pressure of like if it's not good
enough I don't know if we're going to be
able to do another I'm not saying it was
that drastic like it wasn't there yeah
it wasn't that bad but like the work
that they put in compared to say our
Journeys with YouTube where we are
literally playing a video game right now
and yeah you know that's the video and
it's conversation
um it takes us as long as it takes to
stop saying words to be done with it
um but I was telling them like how much
their videos and that effort meant to me
and so many other creators and so many
other people on YouTube their videos
have impacted people they influenced
people I wouldn't be here if it weren't
for their videos I truly don't think I
would
um and it's because they just like they
put in the work to make something
incredible and I'm sure they had so many
different moments where they were like I
don't know if it's good enough I just
gotta go out and that pressure there but
now that I'm working in their office
it's really like I hope that they listen
to me in terms of
just understanding what a difference
they've made because of the effort that
they put in the level of quality that
they maintain so like some people are
just like yeah I make videos for fun and
it should be and I think they're in that
point now where they're able to be more
free and experiment and just try
different videos and try different
things
um yeah but we we are in a bit of a
lucky position
um yeah then again it's like there's a
lot of talbinder I think you have a
great talent for uh entertaining like I
think I have a good voice and that's
about it uh and the show is it's uh it's
it's really like worked out nicely um
I'm not saying it's just like pure hard
work there's obviously some other
factors to it is that the only thing
that you think you're good at is that
you have a good good voice
is there anything else I've never seen
you be so humble no no no no no I I
genuinely think that uh
that you have like some of the best
ideas that I've ever seen in your your
ability to to just think of things and
create things and also like your
stick-to-itiveness
um I think is like so impressive the way
that you you have a goal in mind and you
have a thing that you want to do and
then you just make it happen
um and I I really wish that I had that
kind of trait to just like to just be
able to to push through and like make
things happen and bring an idea to life
because I have a really hard time with
like I'll have a base idea but then
expanding upon an idea and actually
figuring out how to how to create a
thought into a full concept is is really
hard for me sometimes but I think your
ability to like fully make something in
every aspect is really really impressive
because you can take a simple idea that
you have in the back of your mind and
have a full project by the end and I
feel like and obviously like this wasn't
something that you knew how to do off
the
off the bat but like you I feel like you
know you've done such bigger stuff like
space and Heist and everything like that
but I think that you have so many skills
in so many different areas where like I
think a great example of that is um is
the he who doc that we did because that
was basically like your entire idea and
the way that you crafted a narrative out
of what we had and then took that into
the into the editing room if you will
and like we're able to edit that was so
cool and like you did that as well with
uh with the drowned man
um because I I feel like like I wouldn't
be able to take that simple thing of oh
Wade's house is a catastrophe it's
flooding and turn it into like an
engaging really cool narrative piece
um and so I think I think you're
extremely good at that oh thank you but
yeah your voice overall is really weird
yes on top of what you were just saying
I have a question for you which is kind
of the opposite because this is what I
went through
with my show have you have you ever had
sort of like a weird mental break maybe
you did about space where it was like
[ __ ] I really put a lot of myself into
this in a lot of effort into this like
what if this is all I have like what if
what if this is all the juice that I can
give and like what if the what if the
tank is empty after this uh all the time
yeah literally after the end of every
project I have that feeling
um even if I have another idea lined up
because uh I I really do appreciate you
saying that it's very kind of you to say
yeah I do have a lot of ideas but it's
not always perfect you know I do have I
think anyway good drive you know like me
inflating that ball with the power of my
power of the law but it can definitely
backfire me say with my Korean learning
like I've been learning Korean for four
years because of the way my mentality
works I'm like I've been studying it for
four years and language learning is a
very long process and I made a lot of
progress on it but because I'm not there
yet that gets me really depressed
um it's that it's that expectation of
success uh that gets to me uh not in
terms of like view success or anything
like that but my own metric of like did
I accomplish it no well then what the
[ __ ] is wrong I get that a lot um and so
when it comes down to finishing a
project I will be very happy and and
extremely excited but problem for me is
I this is good and bad I'm in love with
the creative process I love everything
about the making of the thing and as
soon as it's out all of that like the
grind is where I really like Thrive and
I love that as soon as it's done there's
just emptiness right it's just suddenly
a vacuum where there's no more work to
be done and it's it gets crippling
sometimes it really does and it it leads
me to suddenly have to feel like I have
to Sprint to do another project just so
I can feel like I'm doing something
um and chasing that dream I've gotten a
lot better at that uh recently
um I've definitely slowed down a lot
especially after space space was one
that was so demanding that I realized
that that was unsustainable I finally
reached the point where the work that
was necessary to make it happen was too
much
um and I kind of like scaled back a bit
and that's what's allowed me to reach
out to other YouTubers
um but yeah I I have doubts all the time
I I've stood pensive was I talking to
were you in the remote I I was talking
about I look out my window with my hands
clasped behind my back my face
illuminated by a little lonely cigarette
I don't smoke
I was like I do that like it's midnight
I'm looking out there and I just go like
God what if that's it am I happy with
that being it uh am I is that good
enough and I think I'm starting to reach
the point where I'm like yeah that I
think I'd be okay with looking back at
all the things that I've done and that
being it I think now you can truly look
back at everything because you have new
eyes you're right I have new eyes I
can't believe I didn't get Lasik sooner
honestly like or smile
smile smile I freaking love it I have to
remind myself that like oh my God I can
see this is incredible I don't have to
take context
legitimately I just can see it's great
it's so cool I love it anyway it's a
sidebar there
um but yeah but now that the show is
over do you feel a little bit of that
pressure of like oh God what if that is
the best that I could do I don't think
it is personally but have you felt that
that intensive look out the window at 12
12 midnight yes
um yeah I definitely I definitely felt
that and that was something that I was
really trying to do during the show
because I did like a little like VIP q a
thing before every show
um and almost every single I think it
was every single show somebody asked me
like you know you worked on this for a
long time like what's next and I
purposely was would never answer that
question I'd be like yeah I'm trying to
just like live in the moment and
appreciate this while it's happening and
I for once was actually able to do that
which I was really excited about
um but yeah I had I did have that a lot
where and I still have that where it's
like damn I worked really hard on that
and I I don't know what I'm going to do
next and maybe I don't have enough juice
and I I think definitely after having a
little bit of time to to sit on it I I
don't have have those doubts as much
anymore where I'm like something will
inspire me and get me thinking in that
way again and I'll do something like
that again and like that that was
another thing that was kind of scary as
well because
people got to see it a bit when we did
you're welcome but especially doing this
show like I really like performing in
front of a live audience and I feel like
I have really good stage presence and I
really like being up on stage like that
and so after having friends and stuff
come to the show and be like wow you're
really good up on stage there's also
that extra pressure now of like [ __ ] I
need to make another thing so I could do
that again yeah no but you are you are
really good I mean you've always been
like incredibly good on camera something
about like when the camera turns on the
back part of your brain that you try to
keep medicinally suppressed surges
forward to your forebrainer just like
emerge is like an alien bursting out
it's really incredible for brain
you know your forebrain yeah you got the
AFT brain you got a forebrain you know
you know
yeah um but no you you are incredibly
good on stage you are incredibly good on
camera that actually is a rare ability
to do it to the degree that you have
because I've now I've seen a lot you
know I'm I mean I'm an experienced old
man I've seen a lot of mad days uh but
no I like I've met a lot of other
creators I've met a lot of other people
it's very rare to see the kind of not
only creative spark and drive to do that
and thrive in the creative process
um but also just like be able to be in
front of a camera at any time in any
circumstance and Thrive like that that
is rare and you should be proud of your
ability to do that
um and I think the thing is like you
will find that you don't need to seek
out opportunities to have that happen it
like they will find you
um because it is rare and it is
something that is sought out and uh
sought after
well thank you I appreciate that of
course um yeah no I I think this this
last couple of years with Lunas honest
and and doing the show and stuff like I
think it it really put a lot of stuff in
perspective for me and especially after
doing the show because I accomplished
the thing it's like oh if I put my mind
to it I can make a thing I can do bigger
stuff because I don't know I I do want
to hold myself to a higher standard and
like I
I don't want to sound shitty but like I
know that I can do things well
and I know that I have potential and I
really don't want to waste that
potential
um how old are you for 25.
[Music]
I don't think you're gonna worry about
wasting your potential at 25 and you've
been doing YouTube for 10 years I think
I think number one you can say that
because you've been doing it for 10
years
um but also you have so much time yeah
not like me
withering away as we speak yeah no but I
think I think you've got plenty of
plenty of plenty plenty of time I want
to see like the movie I want to see like
the first movie you make I know it's
gonna happen at some point I want to see
like
um the next show that you do because I'm
sure that's gonna happen you know I I
know that what you have is not going to
be constrained to what is currently
there because you know not saying that
what's there isn't good enough it's just
like I I think you have the ability to
always be reaching higher and that's
that can be a blessing and a curse but I
think you know I think it'll lead you in
the right direction thanks yeah and like
that's the thing too I want to do that
you know and I I think that it is rare
to find people who aren't satiated by
what they have you know and like I'm
that sounds so bad but like I'm
incredibly grateful to be where I am and
to have been able to do what I do but
like at the same time it's like no I
wanna I wanna do more like this so
you're saying is if losing doesn't make
you mad you don't care about the game
right
right you know what I'm referring to
that ninja tweet yeah the ninja tweet
exactly I see it I see it I always
thought you two were similar I always
thought yeah the blue hair everything no
I I I I'm comfortable with saying like I
really I can respect many creators and I
could be friends with tons of people but
I only want to work with people that
really
want to push themselves creatively it's
not reaching more for more success it's
reaching more inward for more of
yourself and I think that there's
there's a clear distinction but it's
hard to see in certain people yeah but I
see it there is a difference I think we
should do Tunis on us Tunis honest God
I people all the time are like what
would it take for that to happen I was
like a miracle this is what I would take
yeah it's not happening to everybody
this is like you and I am sure will make
so much more stuff together but making a
video like that every single day for a
year again
was not it can't I'm I'm good I'm okay
but I would love to work on many other
projects that's what I think if people
are asking for Tunis on us they did not
embrace the meaning of unisonice in that
it was a singular thing it was done and
over with and there will be more in the
future more memories can be made the
clock is still ticking to this day right
now the clock is still ticking
for you at home
anyway thank you thank you Ethan for uh
joining me on this thank you so much for
having me having me on uh uh uh power
power wash Pals power wash Power Hour
power wash podcast
all of the above and you can find
Ethan's links in the description below
um and if you have any ideas of who you
want to be on the power wash pal podcast
Power Hour uh don't bother in the
comments I pick them myself I don't
actually care what you guys think
watching this
all right later nerds oh man all right
now Elixir do do a classic Unis honest
outro where the Sun hits us and it
explodes and then the aliens come down
and they they take our bodies up into
space but then a part of us is still
alive and we explode the ship from the
inside and there's a spiral into a black
hole okay all right Lucy and you you
heard that uh make Marcus do it
okay cool all right thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]